hi everyone of my name is Tamra chambers
I'm Jake Jarvie and this is Tara Jessa
and Jake was there too we just saw the
or the murder of on the Orient Express
yep directed by Kenneth Branagh mm-hmm
and starring everyone everyone so little
backstory I first got my first Agatha
Christie book when I was like nine years
old and from the time I was like 9 to
like 15 I tried to read all of her books
I have not read any Agatha Christie
books okay but I have seen I have seen
two previous versions of this story okay
one is the 74 film 1970s film and the
other is the BBC David Suchet
PBS they play it on PBS version okay I
stack up well first of all we were in
the front row
it was the reclining seats thank
goodness but we're like the guy next to
us fell asleep he did he was snoring a
bit yeah beginning an act - we lost him
I tapped him on the shoulder she brought
him back
this is gonna be technically spoilers
but woo
yeah it's boilers we spoil it all the
time it's a spoiler because it's already
a book like yeah i looks been out for
like 200 years for sure so like that's
on you it's like when people say that
they don't want to spoil movies i've not
seen for Tam's never seen it's like well
it's my father didn't see Goonies until
yeah 2016 that was my fault so same kind
of thing well it's also the culture
surrounding you their fault for not
forcing it on you thanks mom there is a
group of humans on a train and a murder
happens on this train and it is up to
the great detective Cooper oh I won't
say it Hercules pierot that's what
everyone calls them in the movie that's
how I read it as a child in the book you
know you read names super-wrong oh yeah
yeah oh Hermey on yeah
oh for sure I keep comparing him to like
Sherlock of his time and the greatest
detective who ever lived
right right right he calls himself that
and it is fun in a way that's not that
fun
it's fun in a way that is completely
unmodern yeah that's it it is it's
classical storytelling yeah it's actors
with a 50 millimeter lens right here
acting their hearts out and it is slow
as molasses to our modern sensibilities
it was really soothing yes like even
like laying in the front row next to the
sleeping guy
I understood yeah his situation I mean I
could turn this on before bed yeah I was
just I was just soothe the colors and
just the tone of everything and the way
that you said this the way that they
kind of digitally enhanced the wide shot
just look like a beautiful painting
that's where the you are their budget
other than the cast which everybody was
worth the money like when they line them
all up at the table yeah like the entire
cast and you're looking at them you're
like oh I'm looking at a few million
dollar this is a 20 million dollars
right now we've got the old guard
Michelle Pfeiffer's back killer
cheekbones and all God and we've got the
new guard Daisy Ridley like just shining
like a beacon
I'm just so weird because they didn't
use her name no Daisy was so underused
in a way that hurt my heart because I
just love her so much
well when you have a cast of characters
that large only a few people are gonna
get like a shining character moments
Josh GAD got one Michelle Pfeiffer got
one Josh GAD is he he was the he was the
he was in Beauty and the Beast on OK he
played Lefou
kenneth branagh also directed the movie
also stars as a qrow um and you could
tell he was just like everybody get
ready we're all gonna act our hearts out
yeah last week Cody and I saw Thor and
the director good but but the director
was in the film oh really yes okay in a
very hilarious not needed but wonderful
role and this it's always interesting to
me when the lead is
so the director well this is a kenneth
branagh thing I say Branaugh kenneth
branagh funny that we're talking about
he directed the first Thor movie so now
we're talking Ragnarok he said that yeah
but whenever he does these like this is
not this is a habit of his like doing
old material putting himself as the lead
he played Hamlet in his Hamlet oh he
played dr. Frankenstein and his
Frankenstein it was Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein yeah it's just not
something that I'm used to seeing a
movie that has so much obviously so much
money shoveled into it that is so like
remarkably unremarkable where it's like
there's no so the flash I keep comparing
sugar with a flash of Sherlock is like
something that like I could see this
budget being but like this is a similar
but different kind of mystery type movie
genre movie but it's just it's just so
peaceful and like lovely but like yeah I
don't think modern audiences are really
going to like grasp I felt like a lot of
comfort from it because I it was very
Agatha Christie and it was like very
like old-school theatre and like so I
thought like fun i i'm i'm i'm not like
enthralled by it but I'm comforted yeah
yeah and I agree I enjoy a nice soothing
murder mystery who doesn't where
everyone's nice and polite except for of
course a few like a little bit of racism
right because again classical again
1920s hey we don't know who came for a
Sherlock or oh yeah if arthur corn and
corn oil or AG I don't have my phones
over there mine's dead we could have
found out just like olden times you guys
are watching people have a speculative
conversation something that no longer
exists so I read for Cody's podcast okay
he's got a podcast called tomfoolery and
he reads like really crazy weird books
and we talk about him as comedians and
so we've read the coming of the faeries
by Sir Arthur Conan okay where he and
his later life believed that fairies
were real oh I heard that about him
Oh how's the book it's weird
a lot of facts that fairies exist and
facts that have since been completely
debunked obviously I mean fairies are
real we all know this he was again I
really enjoyed it certain aspects of it
as someone who is diagnosed with OCD I
think that you're diagnosed with OCD
mm-hmm I used to be worse but it's I
don't know but like what I know this if
I watched more of your videos no no okay
but if you saw me organize a closet I
loved watching him interact with like
the shape of things and like I just not
very much like I love that that's very
much written into scared yeah and very
particular true - yeah and you were
saying that you felt he was a little
emotional for my Poirot my first Poirot
so maybe that's why I prefer him
David Suchet okay on those old on the
PBS versions okay and he always was very
at all the times in control of his
emotions and if someone made him mad he
got even quieter so that like kind of
more control is who I believe my my
Poirot is definitely Kenneth Branagh I
did a very good job of that and there
were a couple times where I feel like he
went for emotionality that was uncalled
for
yeah it really was it like deserved in
the moment it felt like they were trying
to pull us in with this lost love
Catherine that he has you can't expect
the audience's read the books yeah yeah
and so it was a very like kind of kind
of done yeah this is the thing about
seeing a movie with an audience I love
to see how it plays to a crowd and the
first half of this movie did not play to
this crowd everybody was so quiet except
for the guy snoring and then the second
half it kind of started to win people
over a little bit we had a hard time
adapting to the classical storytelling
of it as well at the beginning because
everybody jumps in gives you a paragraph
about who they are and dives out which
is a very old storytelling technique and
that's how old stories feel and Agatha
Christie stories especially especially
she's gonna have seventeen hundred
characters coming at you so they are
gonna show up tell you what's distinct
about them and now I'm going to fade
into the
background until we're looking for the
murderer as a kid I used to have a
character chart and I would write yeah
yeah their names and who they were and
then might just continue on see I love
that you would refer to your chart when
they hop back down yeah because they pop
up for another like seven chapters it
was so pretty it was so well acted I
really really enjoy the performances
except from Mickey five yeah especially
up front but I mean she was a mother as
well as a great in my oh man I got she's
moving weight in mother and and I I yeah
she was very much out of it seemed out
of her element but I mean other than
that I thought that acting was great I
just I was missing that suspense what
would you give this oh six out of ten
magnificent mustaches
that's so fair okay I'm gonna give this
and then there were some next week I am
seeing the new Justice League movie I
think oh my god I think it comes out
next week oh my god uh-huh when Jake's
not available have Taylor on my little
brother try to fill this out so that I'm
not just scrambling to talk about Phil
but do they know Cody took off yep they
know mr. mr. Mill's exabyte yeah oh no
no I know I'm wearing a shirt we didn't
talk about how I just don't like when
Johnny Depp doesn't film Oh
dun dun dun dun yeah thanks for watching
everyone see y'all next week
you
[Music]